gm aryan
hello and welcome to the banter blitz i
actually played him
a few games uh some days ago
but he's got a very high rating
so it is probably going to be a tough
game
the khan
oh yeah i think he played this against
me a few days ago
i've never really checked this line with
the computer
i just playing by instinct
so i'm developing my pieces very quickly
he's playing very fast so maybe he has
analyzed this line with
with an engine before
so castles castles and then
i should try to make use of my legion
development
but it's not entirely clear how
now he's attacking both of my pawns
yes i probably have absolutely nothing
here with the white pieces
let's see i'll play queen h5
black is probably absolutely fine in
this position
so i should check this
line with c4 d5 on mode 5
deeper after this because here
black is probably totally fine
he could play knight v6 and exchange
knights
or he could also play knight d7
play knight at six they expect g6
uh nh4
[Music]
now at least i'm threatening bishop h6
with
some sort of an attack
uh yeah i didn't like g6 very much
um
you should ship a three rookie eight and
then knight
f3 with the idea of knight g5
um we should leave it
takes rook the
b1
knight f3 with idf knight g5 wife's
position should be very good here
there are too many threats on his king
and his queen side is undeveloped
knight g5 h5 probably this is
winning knight takes f7
or cap7 win f6
hopefully that's good enough
to win
yeah this should be good enough
yeah what is this three points up and
also an exchange of uh
rook for uh a knight so
maybe maybe i'll play a longer time
control let's see what happens
uh okay